today's topic the baby all right he's
back in the news if you don't know the
baby's a award-winning rapper very very
popular at the moment and uh she's got
danny leigh who's another singer
pregnant she ended up having his kid and
some drama unfolded on ig live get about
my career come on get off my table
i'm stuck hey help essentially
essentially he tries kicking her out of
his place
hurting the child
because she's been staying at his place
for some time and he says we're not
together you need to leave now and she's
like yo how you going to say that you've
been claiming that we've been together
you've been telling me and there are
clips of him saying i love you
i love her
[Music]
that's not enough
so then he does another ig live after he
called the police try to get her out
she's still at the place the next day uh
he does another july basically saying
listen i'm filming it for my own
protection this woman she's trying to
set me up there's hundreds of thousand
people watching and then at one point
they go back and forth and then he says
listen you're not my girl you're just a
side chick and then she loses her mind
because obviously she viewed it a
completely different way
and shout is not my girl
i ain't never been my girl
is my side [ __ ]
it's your wife
shawty is a certified side
her parents know she my side everybody
knows she's assigned
she don't want y'all to push you aside
[ __ ]
she got to save her face she got to
crash all the way out so that's the
summary i don't want to show all the
clips because i think it's just a lot of
nonsense i'm going to say this from both
sides first off
i know a lot of y'all [ __ ] and the
click you came
to click you claim
west side [ __ ] when we quit the
game
you claim to play a player but i [ __ ]
your wife
sorry
first time
first off
yeah great bars some of my favorite
my favorite distraction
i know people say nice ether which i
appreciate
but hit him up is iconic for me first i
know a lot of people are saying hey the
baby's protecting himself he's doing all
this because this girl's crazy yadda
yadda listen record that [ __ ] keep it
offline at the end of the day that's her
kid's mother
that's your kid's mother
regardless of how you feel about her if
you care about that child you don't be
starting no public drama with the baby
mom that's crazy now you're going to
create so much turmoil for that child
what are you doing
and that's my concern all this i don't
really care about the two adults they
can go jump off a bridge for all i care
i don't care they grown-ass people with
their own i don't care they brought a
kid into this world into all kinds of
dysfunction for cliques online
that's distasteful it's also unsafe for
them and on her side she's like man i
thought we was in relationship love like
you talked to me like that boo boo did
you not see his last couple
relationships
do you not see the patterns in this
man's life he got multiple other baby
mamas he had a baby mama while he was
involved with you who was pregnant
people go with somebody who's in a
marriage
they cheat together get married and then
surprise when the person cheats on them
with somebody else
that's the genesis of your relationship
are you surprised when it also ends that
way you feel what i'm saying
[ __ ] took some vows cheated on
his wife to be with you and you think he
gives a [ __ ] about the sanctity of vows
like what's wrong with people
the same way i said pj watch is a bit of
a goober for going for a woman who's
known as a [ __ ] gold digger and then
she dug his gold out i'm also look at
you and not be surprised when this dude
is known as a [ __ ]
baby batter spreader okay and he spreads
some baby batter in you
baby batter
spreader
that's some good bars is it baby batter
spread some butter
got a [ __ ] a nut up in her you know
what i mean it could be some fire [ __ ]
yeah
nutter nutter cracker fire
not doing that
right like you guys got to take
accountability
i'm coming up with a new shirt the
future's not female the future is
accountability we already have that one
we already have i'm ordering it
that's a shirt we have and i'm ordering
it we have it the future is not female
it's accountability the future is female
i don't care i keep the same energy i
said the same thing in the pc watch i'm
gonna say the same this bro
wake up now on the flip side listen guys
you can't be sitting in bed with girls
telling you love them tell them you want
to be with them then be surprised when
they think you're gonna want to be with
them like [ __ ] out here sending
weird signals to people and then
afterwards like now you're my side [ __ ]
then you a deceitful ass [ __ ] i'm sorry
there's some moral character that's
lacking if you're laying in bed with
somebody selling them on dreams that you
have zero intentions we're gonna do this
we're gonna do that we're gonna do that
i love you it's one thing if you change
your mind i could accept that right
maybe you should show you some behavior
okay don't be out here flat out lying
and deceiving people because it starts
to look sus after some time okay guys
there's no way around this we also have
to talk about men who just casually go
out here [ __ ] putting babies in
random people the women also need to be
accountable for their playing their part
but this [ __ ] just got baby mamas
everywhere
making kids have like
single parent households in the world
that's his little name the baby
his whole name is on him on this you
know what his whole good his whole
government is the one the baby mama
baker that's his old government you know
what we're out here talking about grown
[ __ ] over a [ __ ] named the baby that's
the problem
that's the problem [ __ ] is really out
here acting like grown babies
zero responsibility accountability
just putting babies everywhere yeah
the baby mama might care because these
people out here are gonna roast a single
mom for like why'd you get pregnant by
them
why these [ __ ] going out spreading
they see yeah he's doing what he does
you know what i'm saying
like don't glorify this man it's not
good
but that it's not good number one
because here's the thing he got kids
with all he can't give them the time
that they need
no
money is not enough
you know we did a video a while back
about a woman who didn't said i don't
need a father why would my child need a
father yeah because i got money do you
think a child only needs
money from her father
he's doing the same thing
right they're the same people and so you
got kids growing up in affluence but
they dad's out touring or with the other
baby moms or the other kids they got a
bunch of half siblings they don't know
drama in between everything's like
you're creating and fostering [ __ ] up
environments because you can't keep your
dick in your pants remember when you
don't remember when i told you that uh
dysfunction was a new
it was a new
normal normal for them would you say
that you getting too old or the world is
getting too new
[Laughter]
i'm not a serious question are you
getting two holes
or is the world getting to you
[ __ ] weirdos
what you're saying
and i know everybody's picking their
sides i see a bunch of dudes being like
man get out of this nigga's house y'all
gotta leave this man alone and other
women are going like this man is a
cheater like all the rest of like guys
they both hold a whole bunch of l's in
this but you know what the one who's
most important all this is that child
and the fact that they're not
prioritizing means they both deserve a
lot of ridicule and criticism
it's that child who suffers it's the
kids who suffer in all of these kinds of
situations get the [ __ ] off the internet
go be parents
go be parents i said it before
[ __ ] want to have kids they
don't want to be parents everybody want
to have change nobody want to break for
20. listen don't put your [ __ ] out there
first and foremost i don't care
what happened
why are you broadcasting it
out
why do we know your personal [ __ ] if you
just put it on your phone and you tape
it it's tape and then you need to take
it according to the court and that's
gonna be your business but it's no it's
not so much safety
that's [ __ ] cringe son i love you
yeah we love each other yeah we do and
then you press send and you do a whole
post about it
that's corny to all these artists that
do that [ __ ] you corny [ __ ]
because your fan base is a bunch of
weirdo
voyeur
that's what it is i get on the live and
yeah okay we see a picture of your girl
no you [ __ ] weirdo that's none of
your business this is the thing that we
do we do videos
we post it
we give our opinion we funny you watch
it that's it
i don't know nothing about you
you don't know nothing about me and if i
feel safe to say it i'ma say it
but this [ __ ] [ __ ] wordy think
everything
every they need to share everything
ah
[Music]
shut
the [ __ ] up
and then people may oh man let's just
make money with this [ __ ] and they just
oh tonight on news this is not news it's
not news
i don't know how to say it's not news
an artist is doing whatever with some
other
one another that's not news
it's two [ __ ] having problems
we all have our problems you're gonna
film it and bro oh
if there's not some [ __ ] that is cringe
in my life oh my god
i remember that day i remember that day
cardi b was talking some [ __ ] about oh
this my boo this my boo this my boo
y'all [ __ ] can't [ __ ] on us we
better than everybody then he cheated
then they back then she was mad that
people were commenting on oh you should
mind your business no boo-boo no boo-boo
you done broadcasted everything about
your life we're on episode seven of your
life
yeah
oh no we invested now what happens next
and then you gonna be mad because people
are in your business you put your
business out there then you're mad that
people are in your business no this is
not how this [ __ ] works you sold them a
product and then surprised when they
were invested
they paid boo boo
now they're invested god damn i really
went in on that one eh you did i'm not
mad at you go ahead wear that preach
moniker
black yo there's some [ __ ]
dysfunction going on where people think
this kind of [ __ ] is normal yup
people watching this [ __ ] for
entertainment like yo
there's real kids at the other end of
this who are going to be [ __ ] from
this
and they're gonna create other [ __ ] kids
yeah all right
what else let us know what you guys
think in the comments below we want to
hear from you guys what do you think
about everything that's going on we'd
love to hear your thoughts